[Musique]
oui mais voilà comme cécile îles samoa
lundi puis alors c'était même pour
célébrer les 200 chronique de farol
autochtone j'ai voulu me faire un cadeau
et je suis mieux un des endroits les
plus beaux au monde c'est à dire le bord
du fleuve
maintenant ça va faire 200 chronique ces
deux sens semaine que soit je reçois les
questions du public soit je peux
analyser justement ce qui se passe dans
l'espace public
cette chronique c'est pas seulement un
cadeau on m'a fait mais c'est aussi un
privilège et une responsabilité très
importante à mes yeux puisque j'ai un
espace qui très difficile à obtenir
profit qu'un du public pour quelqu'un
qui soit militant ou même qui juste une
citoyenne d'avoir son point de vue sur
une plateforme qui est quand même très
large qui va attendre beaucoup de gens
et pourquoi c'est une responsable ici qu
on me pose des questions on me demande
de commenter l'actualité met dans des
situations qui ont quand même des
impacts politiques les impacts sociaux
qui se trouve aussi des fois dans un
milieu qui peut nécessairement
sécuritaire complètement pour les
communautés qui ne cesse de défendre et
j'essaie de faire valoriser
donc il ya beaucoup de travail qui
derrière ses chroniques et beaucoup
d'appui de la communauté y ait beaucoup
de conseils que je reçois des tirs
beaucoup de délits que je demande aussi
et j'essaye constamment d'avoir un oeil
tourné vers ce qui nous touche le plus
en tant que citoyen donc
ce cadeau c'est de cette plateforme eh
bien j'espère qu'elles répondent aux
besoins de la communauté
ce qui est fantastique ce de plus en
plus j'entends dire que les chroniques
sont soit présenté dans les classes
d'universitaires ou dans les milieux de
travail
elles servent ajustements démystifier
les enjeux tourne autour des questions
qui concernent les différentes
communautés autochtones au québec mais
aussi un peu partout au canada et en
plus
eh bien elle permet de relier deux
communautés qui ce qui peut pas parler
aussi facilement qu'on peut le faire
dans une conversation comme si on était
des vieux amis dont en essayant de
clarifier les enjeux ne s'est pas de
classer les communautés où placer la
culture de programmation des inuits et
des métis dans des bacs ou des paniers
déjà tout prêts déterminés
j'essaie juste d'être déblayée un peu le
chemin pour que les gens puissent aller
se promener et voir alors il ya des
enjeux qu'ils ont intitulé des gens qui
montent beaucoup plus amusant c'est
certain que d'une semaine à l'autre
parler par exemple de racisme systémique
ou parler de bébé yoda et bien ça change
le ton
cependant c'est justement ce que je veux
entendre différents tons et on voit de
plus en plus de jeunes qui approche les
grands médias est de plus en plus de
journalistes fiction formés pour les
grands médias et ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très rassurant parce qu'il faut
pas oublier quand j'ai commencé avec un
moment mais ce dépôt qu'on entende la
voix des communautés autochtones sont
d'accord avec moi comme celles qui ne le
sont pas donc j'espère qu'il parlera la
taxe ne répond à la demande
j'espère que vous y serez pas à nous
envoyer vos questions à partager des
vidéos l isi
les milieux d'enseignement qui peuvent
servir à bénéficier la communauté
alors je remercie de m'avoir écouté
pendant 200 crohn et en espérant que
j'en fasse encore 200 autres qui est
assez de matériel pour y répondre et je
vous souhaite une très belle semaine